nasser c'est considéré comme puissant
outil de recrutement pour le groupe etat
islamique
une vidéo de 10 minutes du djihadiste
ontarien mans en 2013 andré poulet ou
abou muslim selon son nom de combattants
ici andré poulin était considéré comme
un cas isolé de jeunes radicaliser
provenant d'une petite ville et qui
avait eu des démêlés mineures avec les
forces de l'ordre canadienne mais on
apprend maintenant qu'il faisait du
recrutement pour le groupe armé état
islamique dans ce quartier de l'est de
toronto où il vivait selon la sivici
andré poulet a eu des contacts directs
avec cinq jeunes de la ville reine des
jeunes qu'il a soit amené avec lui à
l'étranger ou convaincu de joindre les
rangs djihadistes
parmi eux le torontois mohammed ali ou
abou durable de son nom de combattants
il profère des menaces contre le canada
sur le web
il s'est réjoui entre autres des
attaques à saint jean sur richelieu et à
ottawa
il a toujours affirmé qu andré poulin
était son inspiration
et puis quatre amis torontois
originaires du bangladesh ont suivi
andré poulin lorsqu'il a quitté le
canada pour la syrie via le liban en
2012 il l'appelle est leur chèque leur
leader pris de panique les pères de deux
de ces jeunes se sont rendus eux mêmes
au liban pour les convaincre de revenir
au canada
ils sont tous rentrés à la maison sauf
un andré poulin il s'est finalement
rendu en syrie où il est mort au sein
d'une unité de combattants étrangers du
groupe etat islamique
de retour au canada les quatre garçons
originaires du bangladesh se sont sentis
de plus en plus isolé est frustré trois
d'entre eux sont finalement repartis ils
auraient présumément joint le groupe
armé état islamique
solidaire de la communauté soutient que
les parents de ces combattants inspirés
par andré poulin sont atterrés des pères
installe sceau du poste et qu'ils
attendent encore des nouvelles de leurs
enfants
des nouvelles qui ne viennent toujours
pas il espère également comprendre
comment andré poulin a fait pour les
envoûté à ce point philippe comme c'est
souvent le cas il y avait eu depuis des
signes avant coureurs on le sait
maintenant mais on n'y a pas donné suite
non et certaines personnes disent avoir
entendu andré poulin mentionné qu'il
voulait se rendre en afghanistan qu'il
était furieux contre les soldats
canadiens même qu'un certain moment
donné envoyant des soldats passés devant
la station service où il travaillait il
leur a déclaré qu'il aurait souhaité
avoir en sa possession une bombe pour
les faire exploser
il avait même dit qu'il voulait mettre
le feu à cette station service là parce
que le propriétaire était un musulman un
musulman qu andré poulin considéré comme
un infidèle qui ne partageait pas son
interprétation assez strict du coran
d'ailleurs il a plaidé coupable à des
accusations d'avoir proféré des menaces
mais jamais la grc et le scrs n'ont été
contactés en lien avec monsieur poulin
on n'a pas fini d'en parler merci
beaucoup philippe parsy